[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren und zu einer neuen folge filme
nachts meine gäste heute abend sind die
fdp-politikerin linda teuteberg kult
journalist hans-ulrich jörges glücksrad
und schauspielerin maren gilzer und
unternehmer michael schröder wir
sprechen heute über die doppelmoral von
robert habeck die trans schwimmerin lia
thomas und die lage der menschen die
sich gegen die krone impfung entschieden
haben das konzept der sendung ist sehr
einfach über falls sie doch das erste
mal zugeschaltet haben was ich nicht
hoffe jeder von uns hat einem thema
mitgebracht was ihn schockiert bewegt
oder über das man einfach mal mit
anderen menschen am dienstagabend
debattieren möchte mein aufreger des
tages ist heute deutschlands aktuell für
mich und felix dem ministerium unsere
verteidigungsministerin christine
lambrecht ich möchte jetzt nicht schon
wieder von den helm anfangen erst etwas
weiter zurückgehen auch wenn kompetenz
bei der vergabe von ministerposten
deutschen politikbetrieb der leider
sowieso eher nebensächlich ist ist es
doch etwas besonderes wie wenig geeignet
frau lambrecht auch außerhalb der helme
würde das verteidigungsministerium ist
ihre minister karriere begann im
justizministerium wo sie besonders mit
fragwürdigen beförderung von
parteifreund für aufsehen sorgte laut
einem tagesschau bericht soll sie gut
zuhören angeblich 16 personen befördert
haben bis ihr parteifreund person nummer
17 von der qualifikation her endlich an
der reihe war sein spitzname soll
seitdem gewesen sein nummer 17 nach
ihrer zeit im justizministerium wollte
sie dann eigentlich wieder mit der
politik aufhören und als juristin
arbeiten doch so viel glück hatte
deutschland leider nicht olaf scholz
machte sie zur verteidigungsministerin
und verpasste meiner meinung nach damit
die chance auf eine fähige führung der
bundeswehr die süddeutsche zeitung
berichtete dazu die ersten tage
ministerium begann frostig die alte
führungsmannschaft wurde sofort kalt
gestellt insgesamt scheint lambrecht
eine aversion gegen alles militärische
zu haben mit der aufgabe sich
dienstgrade zu merken schien sie
sichtlich überfordert und nach berichten
von business insider prüft ihr sie sogar
den generalinspekteur aus ihrem budget
beraterkreis zu entfernen ich finde die
bundeswehr braucht endlich jemanden
expertise er dieser aufgabe gewachsen
ist und ja auch jemand der schon mal an
der waffe gedient hat
dem kann ich dir nur zustimmen
grundsätzlich sollte man immer im
unternehmertum eine kompetenz mit mit
sich bringen und auch daraus
resultierend wird man bewertet ich denke
verteidigungsministerium ist eine der 16
ministerien wo man zwingend eine
erfahrung mitbringen sollte eigentlich
auch im gesundheitsministerium
da ist aber zeigt eine separate debatte
zu führen weiter sag' mal der lauterbach
ist ja mit dem zehner
vielleicht zu arg das spezifisch
ausgerichtet deshalb ja aber
grundsätzlich stimme ich dir zu man
sollte auf jeden fall dienst an der
waffe oder den wehrdienst gemacht haben
um den anforderungen eines ministeriums
entsprechen zu können ich glaube das ist
ein ergebnis der falsch verstandenen
quoten politik der spd und auch der cdu
inzwischen dass es ja inzwischen schon
die dritte frau die auf diesem stuhl
sitzt im verteidigungsministerium alle
drei haben einen scherbenhaufen
hinterlassen begann mit ursula von der
leyen die eigentlichen intelligente
politikern ist aber auch keinen zugang
zu dem thema hatte und dass angela
merkel kanzlerin war in den letzten
jahren hat auch damit zu tun in welchem
zustand wir heute die bundeswehr
vorfinden wenn frau lampe verlag frau
lamprecht wäre ja nicht auf diesen stuhl
gekommen wenn die spd nicht sich im
zwang gesehen hätte
halbe-halbe männern frauen auf
ministerposten zu erheben wenn lars
klingbeil
verteidigungsminister geworden wäre was
ich mir gewünscht hatte persönlicher
dienst eine waffe ging da auch nicht
gegen hat es trotzdem der hat aber den
verteidigungsausschuss der hat sich mit
den themen ständig beschäftigt er kommt
aus einer soldaten familie der schon als
jugendlicher da aufgewachsen dem milieu
wenn der klingbeil minister geworden
wäre wäre uns auch karl lauterbach
erspart geblieben als
gesundheitsminister welche freude müsste
man heute sagen weil der wehr eine frau
gesundheitsministerium geworden wer
immer das gewesen wäre wären auf jeden
fall besser gewesen als lauterbach finde
ich auf jeden fall vor allem viel mehr
wertschätzung für unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten und die bundeswehr weil was
jetzt bevorsteht es ja wirklich
weiterhin die debatte manche fangen da
ja schon wieder zu zweifeln an daran
dass die sondervermögen wichtig und
richtig ist für die bundeswehr es geht
nicht um aufrüstung es geht überhaupt
mal um ausrüsten dass unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten angemessen ihre aufgabe
wahrnehmen können ich glaube da haben
wir noch viel zu tun dass wir richtige
wehrhaftigkeit nicht verwechseln mit
militarismus
sondern wissen wir brauchen eine
wehrhafte bundeswehr um unsere freiheit
um den frieden zu verteilen freut heute
werk hat er jedes recht das
verteidigungsministerium ein toten
ministerium ist die es mir auch schon
ich glaube das geht für verschiedene
positionen und so normal und ich bin
auch nicht so der meinung dass politiker
fachleute sein müssen aber sie müssen
sie müssen durchsetzungsfähig sein ich
glaube sie müssen guten überblick haben
da ist eigentlich das was frau lambrecht
mitbringt juristin gar nicht so schlecht
man muss sich nämlich auch nicht von
beamten erzählen lassen was geht oder
was nicht geht aber am ende ist das
keine spezifische frage ist eine frage
glaube ich nicht eher der erfahrungen
der herangehensweise einen guten
überblick zu haben durchsetzungsfähig zu
sein stimmt das braucht die bundeswehr
besonders bei jungtieren prinzip hat
frau lambrecht alles nicht was sie jetzt
aufgezählt haben
bundeskanzler jetzt begonnen hat die
verwendung der 100 milliarden für die
rüstungsprojekte der bundeswehr selbst
in die hand zu nehmen mit dem
generalinspekteur drüber zu reden da
sitzt frau lambrecht mit dabei muss ich
ja wohl auch aber er hat es selbst in
die hand genommen hat natürlich auch
damit zu tun wie er seine eigene
verteidigungsministerin einschätzt da
kann ja viel mal von pratt rutschen das
sind von den 100 milliarden schnell mal
50 weg und man weiß gar nicht wohin also
da muss man sehr aufpassen
auch das ist übrigens eine menge von
fehlleistungen aufgezählt dass die
ministerin nicht mal einen ansatz
unternommen hat eine gruppe von
kompetenten leuten zusammen zu rufen die
den auftrag haben die verwendung darum
dass militärische sein und konnte sich
nicht mehr die ganze ja aber das hat
wahrscheinlich auch der grund dass
deutschland sowieso in den letzten
jahren sich sehr pazifistisch
aufgestellt hat immer wenn es mehr
waffen und dann war man ja ganz ein ganz
böser mensch und man sagt dann ja auch
ja frauen die sind gerade in dem bereich
ja viel besser weil die reden die
greifen nicht gleich zur waffe die sind
diplom
das nennt sich feministische
außenpolitik
ich glaube das hat uns in den
vergangenen jahren sehr verfolgt und
diese üble rechnung müssen wir jetzt
einfach bezahlen dass wir uns einfach zu
sehr auf den frieden vertraut haben und
gemeint haben wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass der frieden erhalten bleibt indem
wir reden
haben ja vieles falsch verstanden auch
gedacht dass wir von russland abhängig
sind ist nur gut für uns ja die russen
liefern zuverlässig ja das tun sie schon
aber von wem kriegt man das soll jetzt
vor also haben glaubt wenn die
wirtschaft nicht mit den russen
zusammenarbeiten dann sind sie auch
wirtschaftlich von uns abhängig und
deswegen lassen sie uns leid so können
wir gleich reden sie hat diplomatie ist
gut aber man muss natürlich angst
genommen werden damit das was bringt und
dafür muss man so stark sein dass für
die andere seite nicht verhandeln keine
option ist und das essen vernachlässigt
worden ja immer und ich glaube darüber
brauchen wir noch eine echte debatte da
gibt es noch einige die noch nicht so
weit sind dass wir jetzt wirklich ganz
konsequent die bundeswehr so ausstatten
und nicht schon wieder überlegen wie
können wir das für irgendwelche anderen
zwecke noch ein bisschen verteilt wobei
ich würde gern einschränken wenn das sag
ich mal niemand ist davon ausgegangen
dass jetzt hier ein angriffskrieg aus
russland ausgeht und dass die bundeswehr
jetzt so explizit in fokus gerät ja man
ging davon aus dass läuft immer so da
war die vorgängerin war ja auch eine
frau da war auch bundeswehr auf jeden
fall beliebter gewesen sein also ich
habe immer frau kramp karrenbauer
ehrlich gesagt bei manchen bundesweiter
dann sehr gutes gehört oder habe ich
etwas anderes bild auf über gespiegelt
bekommt von einzelnen auch vom
bundestagsabgeordneten
die sollen nicht ganz so daneben er wohl
gewesen wollte ja auch manches
beschaffen wo andrea gegen gewährte ja
hört ja zur realität der jahre dazu das
nicht wenig blockiert wurde auch was die
ausrüstung gehört sich auch kein
generalinspekteur geholt auch aus dem
saarland wie sie selber und ich weiß bin
nicht so sicher ob das und das richtige
merkmal war um ein generalinspekteur
auszuzeichnen das aus dem saarland kommt
aber manchmal vertrag meine in der
razzia land ist keine besondere
militärmacht niemals gewesen
aus deutschland haben wir besondere
stimmt vielleicht sollte man auch über
die rolle der unserer soldaten mal
passieren weil wenn zb so etwas wie
hochwasser oder entnehmen oder andere
katastrophen passieren warum dauert es
dann so lange bis man die ins boot holen
kann damit die einen helfen als wenn es
schon nicht im krieg ziehen so allein da
haben wir ja sehr viel gemacht die
letzten jahres ist ja eher so dass viele
sich daran gewöhnt haben immer nach der
bundeswehr zu rufen frau kiefer ja auch
hier in berlin jetzt beim thema
flüchtlinge jetzt umso wichtiger ist
dass wir in erinnerung rufen auch da
leistet die bundeswehr viel aber es ist
nicht ihr kernauftrag und wir müssen sie
jetzt mal ihren kernauftrag erfüllen
lassen und dafür richtig ausstatten sie
wird gerne bei katastrophenschutz bei
irgendwelchen personal knappheiten auch
noch impfen und so genutzt kosmix aber
wir brauchen sie natürlich für ihren
kernauftrag ja ich wollte noch 12 quoten
frage sagen ich bin sehr dafür quoten
anzulegen bei der auswahl von
mandatsträgerinnen und mandatsträger
also bei bundestagsabgeordneten
kandidaten für parlamente bei ämtern bin
ich ganz anderer meinung da bin ich der
meinung da kommt es auf qualifikationen
an da sollten die bewerber schon mal was
mit dem thema zu tun gehabt haben und
nicht nach du findest als man sollte die
quote von unten ansetzen ja sie
irgendwann oben ankommen parlamente
müssen unterbesetzt seien aber bei den
ämtern es ist eine andere frage man muss
jemanden finden im
verteidigungsministerium der schon mal
mit der bundeswehr zu tun hatte davon
was versteht der auch mal eine waffe in
der hand hatte möglicherweise und
jedenfalls der nicht völlig neu lernen
muss aber die frage ist ja schon bei der
über der quoten sache die du gerade
angesprochen hast es gibt ja die theorie
dass man unten anfangen muss auch im
unternehmen also dass man anfangen
sollte ab dem niedrigsten level damit es
sich dann hochziehen kann und dann oben
die leistungsträger beide geschlechter
haben und da ist eine quote oben nichts
bringen würde
sollte könnte man denn dann ist das
natürlich nicht auf gefragt und die
frage würde ich gerne eine frau
teuteberg spielen als politikerin warum
gibt es nicht in jedem
wirtschaftsunternehmen gibt es ein
anforderungsprofil
also ich kann jetzt nicht hochgehen zu
herr bode und sagen so ich bin eine frau
ich möchte es gerne chef an den türen
werden war zwar erst 2017 im volontariat
aber ich wäre es jetzt gerne schon mal
also wieso gibt es keine
anforderungsprofil wie in jedem
wirtschaftsunternehmen auch für die
politik das habe ich nicht immer gefragt
zum beispiel verteidigungsministerium
warum muss ist nicht jemand sein krudes
vorgemacht in kanada er hat ja sein
kabinett damals so aufgestellt dass sie
auch vorfahren hatten warum gibt es
nicht wie so ein bewerbungsbogen wo man
ein paar fähigkeiten haben mussten die
politik hat da eigene gesetze und
logischen wobei ehrlich gesagt bei denen
die als kanzler oder kanzlerin sorgt hat
so der regierungschefs
besetzen können wenn sie dann nehmen die
können natürlich trotzdem sinnvollen
kriterien anlegen aber ansonsten ist es
natürlich so in parteien und in vielen
bereichen dass sie aus ehrenamt das im
ehrenamt geht und dass sie erst einmal
sehen müssen welche menschen engagieren
sich und wer will denn für etwas
kandidieren oder verantwortung
übernehmen also sie haben auch nicht wie
in der wirtschaft natürlich die üblichen
möglichkeiten über gehalt und andere
dinge menschen zu fördern oder leistung
zu belohnen oder schlechtleistungen zu
bestrafen also da gibt es viele gründe
aber wenn es um ämter geht um
regierungsämter hat das natürlich viel
mit den personen zu tun die entscheiden
werde ja auch entscheidungsträger wollen
sich gerne die handlungsfähigkeit
erhalten und möglichst wenig kriterien
haben die ihnen die handlungsfähigkeit
einschränken deshalb wird wie bei das
erlebt haben bei olaf scholz bis zum
letzten moment hin und her geschubst und
dann war die frage also
lauterbach wird gesundheitsminister da
muss eine frau verteidigung machen da
sitzen wir jetzt gar in diesem loch
sitzen wir jetzt und 2 sind sie in
wahrheit zwei löcher ja das war ja das
ganz wichtig noch mal mit der quote
theorie aufzuschließen die landen recht
debatte und wir gehen weiter zu dem
unternehmer der runde und zwar freue ich
mich jetzt auf ihre these herr schröder
die ja was mit robert habeck zu tun hat
dementsprechend hat er bei der politiker
aufgeregt die woche ja ich sag mal so
robert habeck hat mich leicht irritiert
oder ich war erschrocken es ist geplant
strom
gas aus katar
ist die frage ist es die richtige
entscheidung wie wir alle wissen wir
sind abhängig von fossilen
energieträgern wie kohle putin gas und
öl wir wissen genau diese ressourcen
sind begrenzt was wiederum zu resultat
für das explodierende strom und
energiepreise gibt die frage die wir uns
stellen sollten wie schaffen wir es eine
kluge und saubere klimapolitik zu
gestalten ohne gleichzeitig auf den
wohlstand zu verzichten bzw zu gefährden
kurzfristig habe insbesondere auch
langfristig ich sage saubere energie aus
der wüste desertec die vision von
desertec ist vor 15 jahren ins leben
gerufen und wurde von der politik bisher
nicht ausreichend unterstützt nun ist
die zeit dazu reif definitiv die lösung
großflächige wind und solaranlagen in
der wüste bevorzugt in nordafrika der
transport der generierten energie
erfolgt über unterwasserkabel über
stromtrassen oder per schiff wir haben
ausreichend frei verfügbare flächen in
den wüsten um den kompletten
energiebedarf der erde zu lösen bzw zu
decken deutschland und europa muss
endlich aufwachen schauen wir nach china
in china entstehen derzeit 450 gigawatt
an wind- und solarkraftwerken das
entspricht in etwa 400 atomkraftwerken
das heißt china macht sich komplett
unabhängig von energieimporten aber auch
von fossilen energieträgern will
deutschland und europa den wettbewerb
erneut hinterher rennen
ich sage nein ich sage setzt auf strom
aus der wüste macht euch machen wir uns
gemeinsam unabhängig ich habe kürzlich
gelesen journal aus amerika sagte
deutschland macht weltweit die
schlechteste energiepolitik lieber herr
beck das sollten wir ändern ich stehe
mit rat und tat zur seite
der kniefall waren das den aktiv aber
robert habeck ist natürlich auf
schwieriger mission und die misere mit
der erst jetzt zu tun hat die hat viele
mütter und väter das sind natürlich die
die nur über ausstieg reden geredet
haben den letzten jahren auch bei kohle
oder atom da waren die grünen dabei
aber natürlich auch viele andere die zu
große abhängigkeit von russland da waren
viele dabei das falsch einzuschätzen
und atomkraft wurde beschleunigt der
ausstieg da haben wir viel zu tun und
die optionen die sie genannt haben die
wohnt so wenig verfolgt also
technologieoffenheit und die sonst so
viel gerühmte vielfalt also hier auch
diversifizieren bei den energieträgern
das ist sträflich vernachlässigt worden
aber da waren waren die grünen nicht die
einzigen die ihren anteil daran haben
und robert habeck muss jetzt in kurzer
zeit dafür sorgen dass wir alternativen
finden insofern ich würde ihn nicht so
hart verurteilen aber die energiepolitik
der letzten jahre die ist gescheitert
ich würde ihnen noch schärfer
vorurteilen also wahrscheinlich jeder
hier weiß ich finde das ist schade wir
machen es wahrscheinlich zusammen und
stehen mir es ist ja blöd wenn ich
darüber rede wie schlimm ist alles was
er habe mit katar macht lassen wir doch
einmal herrn farbig erklären warum er
hat ihr ein video aufgenommen mit einem
land wie katar jetzt geschäfte machen
möchte die menschenrechte werden da ja
nicht so richtig gewagt aber hören wir
doch mal wieder dass ein herr haar
exporten klingt das ist natürlich eine
politisch sagen wir interessante region
das nicht immer angesprochen habe sind
die arbeits und menschenrechte die
natürlich ein großes thema sind es gibt
nur 300.000 kataris zehn prozent der
bevölkerung drei millionen menschen
leben hier der rest arbeitet hier häufig
nicht so ganz guten bedingungen
damals und menschenrechte in katar die
diskussion ist uns bekannt seitdem wir
über die fußball-wm reden das ist das
halte ich auch nicht für relevant
sondern ich mir wird es ein bisschen
schwierig wenn wir dabei sind ein
politisches risiko russland durch ein
anderes politisches risiko arabische
länder einzutauschen da kann jeden tag
an politischer umsturz stattfinden in
den emiraten aber auch in nordafrika
kein staat ist demokratisch sicher und
verlässlich und ich finde wir sollten
aus dem russland abenteuer insofern
lernen dass wir uns bei den energie
importen ausschließlich auf dem mond
zwar auf sauber regierte demokratische
staaten verlassen das sind die usa
kanada australien
europa natürlich und ansonsten sollte
man die finger davon lassen vielleicht
kleinere mengen die nicht maßgeblich
sind für unsere gesamte aber das sollten
wir gelernt haben und damit bringen wir
es auch zusammen ich weiß nicht ob wir
nicht in zehn jahren komisch aus der
wäsche gucken wenn das was sie auf der
bühne aufgebaut haben von irgendwelchen
islamisten ab gekappt wird die dort die
macht übernommen ich zeige ja der text
für sauberen wüstenstrom für europa wäre
natürlich am besten nordafrika aber es
gibt ganz andere wüste atacama wüste in
chile da gibt es ein pilotprojekt von
volkswagen porsche siemens gemeinsam mit
enel dem energieversorger aus italien
die machenden pilotprojekt um zu
generieren also es ist nicht zwingend
nordafrika
limitiert da der mittlere osten macht
sehr genau so da sind wiederum die
chinesen involviert shanghai electric
baut gemeinsam mit dem saudi-arabischen
aqua energieversorger dort genau das was
wir schon seit jahren fordern ja das ist
die unabhängigkeit und man kann vor
allem transportieren man kann
wasserstoff generieren und die
politische instabilität ist was sie
gerade sagten widerspreche ich tunesien
marokko überall macht man urlaub
russland hat man jahrelang sage ich mal
unterstützt daher mal in marokko konnte
man vom halben jahr schon keinen urlaub
mehr machen im november kreise weil die
diplomatischen beziehungen quasi
eingefroren waren weil sich deutsche
touristen da gar nicht um ungehindert
aufhalten konnten also das ist abhängig
aber auch hier reden weil jeder rolle
was alles geht wir haben auch in den
letzten jahren viel zu vielen über
ausstiege nur schöngeredet und nicht wo
wir neu einsteigen soll ich doch dazu
gehörige portion antiamerikanismus weil
nämlich zum beispiel das thema
flüssiggas sehr früh generell verteufelt
wurde jetzt heißt es plötzlich terminal
wird gebaut für lg flüssiggas es bis vor
kurzem immer blockiert worden und
übrigens nicht zuletzt auch mit dem
argument mag sein dass es teuer ist es
ist auch aufwendig aber im verhältnis
dazu von wem wir uns sonst abhängig
machen und wenn man dann mal wieder die
gretchenfrage stellt wo rufen wir an
wenn wir schutz brauchen wir probleme
haben in moskau oder in washington dann
dürfte die antwort klar sein trotzdem
haben wir wurde über jahre mehrheitlich
ausgeschlossen dass flüssiggas überhaupt
ein teil unserer energieversorgung sein
kann sowieso sich aus dieser illusion
und aus dieser naivität wachen jetzt
viele auf das wichtigste ist die uhr
fähigkeit des kids hauptsächlich
deutschland und europa muss sich
unabhängig machen wie china china macht
er jetzt die macht sich komplett
unabhängig oder einfach ein großes nicht
von denen die eine bedrohung sind die
amerikaner hatten doch auch recht damit
indirekt jetzt ist dass das große thema
bei uns dass wir natürlich über diese
fossilen energieträger sehr wohl die
aufrüstung finanzieren in russland also
da war ja was dran während wir
gleichzeitig die zwei prozent in der
nato nicht einhalten als deutschland
also diese dieser ärger in amerika der
übrigens nicht nur was mit trump zu tun
hatte sondern über alle politischen
lager hinweg über deutschland und europa
gab es da unmut in amerika der war ja
nicht unberechtigt aber letztendlich
haben wir immer noch keine schnelle
lösung es gibt tolle ideen und tolle
erfindungen liegen offenen tür schock
gerade was den wasserstoff angeht hat
man dort auch wesentlich ja genau schon
vor 20 jahren bin ich da shuttle service
mit bmw abgeholt worden warum ist es so
leise ja der ist mit wasserstoff
betrieben aber die lobbyisten die haben
sich einfach durchgesetzt sie wollten
weiter eben benzin und öl und
verbrennungsmotor und unterkonten die
sich damit nicht durchsetzen aber die
ganzen pläne davon liegen seit vielen
vielen jahren in den schubladen
aber das jetzt so schnell zu aktivieren
so schnell wie wir es brauchen dass es
eben das probieren und zum teil sehr
schnell kohle können sie sofort in
australien kaufen öl und gas kann man
aus der nordsee bekommen von
verschiedenen ländern darf man nicht so
viel kriegen in norwegen gab es gerade
ein erdbeben weil die sehr viel gas aus
der erde holen das ist für die zum teil
sei es nur logisch gefährlich darf nicht
zu viel sein aber ich wiederhole noch
mal usa kanada europa austragen
preispolitik uli zurück man muss
natürlich auch immer sehen war sei
aber jedenfalls das ist ein
zweitrangiges argument weil wir müssen
los von russland und wir müssen russland
sehr viel stärker sanktionieren als was
bisher tun darum energie
ich weil die entsorgung nicht geklärt
ist um es klar zu sagen und die wird
auch nicht geklärt werden wir noch fünf
jahre verlängern dagegen habe ich im
prinzip nichts wenn man das brauchen
aber die entsorgungsfrage ist immer noch
offen und sie ist überall oft ist es
nirgendwo geklärt und es ist auch nicht
billig und es gibt zum beispiel können
wir uns da jahren bei spiel in china zum
beispiel nehmen das habe ich beim
letzten mal schon angelegt aber keiner
kannte sich scheinbar damit aus das ist
die sind diese thorium reaktoren die in
china entwickelt werden das sind
reaktoren die eigentlich ähnlich
funktionieren wie ein kernkraftwerk aber
sie sind viel kleiner und produzieren
viel viel weniger atommüll und vor allen
dingen das was man dazu braucht das
kriegen wir alles hier aus unserem boden
wir brauchen keine tolle seltenen erden
kaufen oder irgendwas es ist eine
preiswerte und
relativ umweltfreundliche
energieversorgung die man vielleicht
einsetzen könnte bis man wirklich
alles andere technisch so auf den stand
gebracht haben uns fehlen einfach nur
die wissenschaftler die sitzen in china
diese sonst wo die sind sie jetzt schon
wieder schneller als wir gibt es ja viel
in deutschland am ernst die sind alle
stillgelegt worden weil alle
reaktorlinien es gibt jetzt irgendwie
sie zurecht ganz verschiedene atomare
entwicklungslinien die sind alle
eingestellt worden also wir waren ja zum
teil auch bei kleinen kugelhaufen
reaktoren und anderen weniger
gefährlichen reaktoren dies sind zum
teil schon hier gebaut worden im versuch
uns alles vorbei ich habe dann könnte
man wieder aktiviert habe man schon aber
wohl nicht man den müll händen das ist
die ungeklärte fahrrad des jungen
geklärte frage aber man kann nicht
darauf von aus can bring den müll hin
und schaltet
atom abschaltet kohle ab und hat keine
alternativen nämlich bin hier für sie
als edel insofern recht dass man die die
noch bestehenden kernkraftwerke ein paar
jahre verlängert das sagen alles geht
gar nicht viel zu teuer und so weiter
wenn man es braucht muss man es tun der
meinung bin ich auch zeichnet nach wie
vor in afrika entstehen 900
kohlekraftwerke in südostasien
5000 sollen entstehen kohlekraftwerke
ich sage immer klimawandel hört nicht an
der deutschen grenze auf also man muss
zielgerichtet überlegen wie kann man es
lösen und entweder es gibt nur die zwei
varianten weltweit dafür kämpfen stehe
ich und kämpfe darauf höre auch entweder
atomenergie oder wüstenstrom es geht nur
die zwei varianten und dann es gibt die
grünen
die atomenergie aber es den
nachbarländern kaufen oder von ländern
wo die reaktoren nicht so sicher sind
wie bei uns dann und für teures geld
dann bringt das ja auch nicht wir
brauchen schon alternativen weil
letztendlich ist die kernenergie nicht
des pudels kern und die beste lösung wir
sollten schon das irgendwie eliminieren
irgendwann aber es gibt alternativen wir
müssen uns einfach nur man muss auch
kaufmännisch denken die strompreise
explodieren die energiepreise im
allgemeinen und warum explodieren weil
wir eine höhere
eine höhere nachfrage haben und das
angebot fällt das ist ja schlichtweg der
punkt und mit wüstenstrom können wir
zumindest das angebot erhöhen also was
in der deutschen debatte über die frage
der energiepreise unterversorgung nicht
öffentlich mit diskutiert wird ist ja
die frage liebe nena da du immer sagt
was kostet das dann ist die frage woher
man so nennt man die preise auch nähen
woher man ich bin ja kein mehrfach nadja
ist die frage das abschalten von
gasversorgung zur heizung von wohnungen
sich überhaupt nicht stellt weil nach
den geltenden deutschen gesetzen die
wohnungen bis zum schluss versorgt
werden und das ist ungefähr ein drittel
dass das des bedarfs und dann kommt die
industrie obendrauf die allerdings ist
dann jener branche ist die gefährdet
wenn an den gas- abgeschaltet wird aber
das sagt ja sogar herbeck bis zum
jahresende haben wir gar kein problem
also bis zum nächsten winter warum sagt
dieses land nicht ich rede jetzt über
sanktionen gegen russland warum ist
dieses land nicht in der lage zu sagen
wir steigen jetzt aus und üben maximalen
druck auf butt hinaus und sagen bis zum
nächsten winter das schaffen wir den
satz haben wir schon mal gehört ich
glaube auch das können wir schaffen die
diskussion können wir jetzt nicht
aufmachen denn auf sie wartet eine kurze
unterbrechung und dann geht es weiter
mit hans ulrich jörges der über die lage
der nicht geimpften bevölkerung in
deutschland sprechen möchte bis gleich
[Musik]
noch vier tage
das box highlight live bei bild
[Musik]
felix sturm auf dem weg zum
weltmeistertitel
der kampf gegen israel
willkommen zurück
die boxnacht
samstag bei
dieser sendung wird präsentiert von
governor of poker 3 die gratis poker app
fürs handy
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück liebe
zuschauer bei 48 und wir legen jetzt
direkt los mit dem statement von hans
ulrich jörges zu der lage der nicht die
impften menschen in deutschland in der
vergangen woche habe ich hier
die ungeimpften symbolisch um verzeihung
gebeten wegen der hitze und der
diskriminierung gehe sie über viele
monate ausgesetzt waren die reaktion war
überwältigend ist und zum teil sehr
emotional ich habe daraus gelernt über
dieses thema müssen wir öffentlich reden
es ist notwendig dass wir besprechen
dass es millionen von menschen gibt in
deutschland die zutiefst verletzt sind
weil andere millionen sich überhaupt
nicht umgekehrt haben was mit ihnen
passiert das geht nicht weiter runter an
die medien auch eine ganz gute rolle
gespielt es gibt viele übergriffe aus
den medien ich will ein paar erwähnen im
morgenmagazin des zdf sind ungeimpfte
als verfassungsfeind bezeichnet worden
beim berliner tagesspiegel ist der
wunderbare kolumnist harald martenstein
aus dem blatt geekelt worden weil er
geschrieben hatte wenn ungeimpfte mit
dem judenstern auf demonstrationen zögen
dann sei das zwar anmaßend aber nicht
antisemitisch gastes zweifelsfrei
richtig aus meiner sicht dann sind beim
rbb die ungeimpften mitarbeiter über
nacht aus dem sender geworfen worden
dass es am tag vor weihnachten verkündet
worden ich persönlich bin in einem ruf
mörderischen artikel als schutzpatron
der ungeimpften bezeichnet worden das
hatte die absicht mich der
journalistisch zu erledigen ich weiß
also ein bisschen wovon ich rede aber
ich bin ja geimpft und nicht ungeimpft
und ich finde wir müssen hier
wir müssen hier öffentlich etwas für
diese menschen tun der bundespräsident
hat er zunächst mal muss sich einwerfen
wir haben uns ja inzwischen was die
basis der ganzen diskussion angeht daran
gewöhnt wir haben eingesehen dass es was
die infektions leistung angeht also die
ansteckungsgefahr angeht keinen
unterschied zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften
und das ist außerdem in den in den
intensivstationen geimpfte neben
ungeimpften liegen da können wir gar
keinen unterschied mehr feststellen
trotzdem wird aber diese kampagne gegen
die ungeimpften fortgesetzt ich möchte
einen satz aus der frankfurter
allgemeinen sonntagszeitung vom gesamt
phase vom vergangenen wochenende
vorlesen zitat und wer sich bis heute
keine spritze hat geben lassen die
maßnahmen für übertrieben und das virus
für harmlos hält sollte ohnehin nicht
der erste sein der seine freiheit zurück
bekommt das ist ein ungeheurer satz das
heißt in diesem land gibt es zwei sorten
von freiheit die erste klasse haben
diejenigen sich haben impfen lassen und
die zweite klasse haben vielleicht
diejenige die sich nicht impfen lassen
der bundespräsident hat kürzlich gesagt
es gebe eine hat er hat die die stille
mehrheit wie er es genannt hat im land
aufgerufen sie sollten sich zu wort
melden mit der stimmenmehrheit meinte er
die geimpften die sollten sich gegen die
ungeimpften zu worte melden ich finde er
selbst sollte sich zu wort melden um den
ungeimpften ihre rechte zurück zu geben
und ihnen gerechtigkeit widerfahren zu
lassen wir brauchen keinen
bundespräsidenten der eine mehrheit
aufwiegelt wir brauchen ein der die
minderheit schützt
als es zu dem thema kann ich nur sagen
so wie ich es lebe und auch eigentlich
die meisten in meinem umfeld
ich verhalte mich so dass ich möglichst
andere nicht gefährde
und sind sie dann geh ich bin gepustet
und werde mich auch ein viertes mal ich
werde wenn es jemand sagt der von
medizin mehr ahnung hat als ich und das
sind ganz viele und wenn die sagen
musste ich zweimal im jahr impfen lassen
dann werde ich es machen nicht nur zum
eigenen schutz sondern auch um
sicherzugehen dass mein umfeld geschützt
ist und auch
uns dabei zu unterstützen dass die
pandemie lang von vorbei ist dass wir
ein annähernd normales leben führen dass
wir auf partys gehen können dass hier
wieder spaß haben können dass ich nicht
wenn ich im zug sitze nachher gelder ein
versprechen was nie eingelöst wurde also
geimpft und gepustet und was ja also
stark und trotzdem dürfen die leute ja
nicht ich hin ist schlimm dass ich fünf
stunden im zug sitzen muss mit einer
maske und mir ist dann über hinterher
und ich will dass das irgendwann mal
aufhört und ich tue alles dafür dass das
irgendwann mal aufhört für uns hier in
deutschland und das ist mir wichtiger
als dass es eventuell eine nebenwirkung
gibt oder dass ich meine demokratische
freiheit ausleben kann mir ist alles
andere wichtiger als diese beiden punkte
noch nimmt oftmals höhere orgel vor ein
bin gehe ich auch nicht auf die straße
gelassen erstmal vorteile gibt es auch
fraglich weil auch keine menschen keine
politiker tätig angreifen weil die
anderer meinung sind dass ich möchte
dass meine meinung respektiert wird
genau so wie ich auch die meinung der
ungeimpften respektiere und sage wenn du
da ängste hat und es nicht machen willst
aus irgendwelchen gründen da mache es
nicht wo ich das auch heute heute das
schlimme ist dass die die pandemie bei
manchen die sehnsucht nach einfachheit
sich dann auch so auswirkt moralische
rigorosität
sündenbock suche sündenbock denken
einerseits muss ich ein yorks ein
bisschen widersprechen es gibt schon
noch ein unterschied bei der viruslast
und auch bei der schwere der
erkrankungen zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften aber trotzdem für mich ist
ganz wichtig als liberale es ist die
entscheidung von erwachsenen menschen
selbst welche medizinischen eingriffe
sie an sich vornehmen lassen und das
muss ich respektieren und der
unterschied ist allerdings unter omikron
erst recht nicht mehr so stark
was das thema infektionsrisiko und so
weiter angeht deshalb bin ich gegen eine
impfpflicht ich glaube auch nicht
übrigens dass manche ungeimpften die
sich so ein bisschen jetzt allgemein als
opfer stilisieren oder als seien sie
mündiger als alle die sich geimpft haben
dass es genauso falsch aber ich habe was
gegen diese suche nach sündenböcken und
ganz gefährlich an dem was sie da
zitiert haben ist nämlich diese denke
als ginge es um bestrafung oder
belohnung im freiheitlichen rechtsstaat
ist das keine frage von gnade oder
wohlwollen obmann freiheit hat sondern
der staat darf nur so wenig wie möglich
so viel wie unbedingt nötig die
freiheitsrechte einschränken und da und
das ist einfach so schlimm dieses
bevormundende dieses erzieherische
dieser impetus und der greift immer mehr
um sich wir müssen noch mal erkennen
dass wir unsere erwartungen ans impfen
ich bin genauso wie sie gemeistert
ständig zurückgenommen haben anfangs
haben wir gedacht wenn wir geimpft sind
stecken wir uns auch gar nicht mehr an
und wir können noch andere nicht
anstecken das wurde auch übrigens mit
der masken pflicht verbunden dann haben
wir gemerkt das stimmt ja gar nicht
besondern wir sind als gebucht hatte
selber in der lage andere menschen
anzustecken ich habe im moment meine
beiden töchter und deren männer sind
alle gemeistert und alle corona krank im
selben moment die haben gar kein umgang
mit ungeimpften weil sie darauf achten
dass haben sie also von gm
er ist eine sache für die ich mich
entschuldigen wenn ich hab's auch hier
auch bei villach gemacht ich werde ab
jetzt nur noch sagen menschen die sich
gegen die impfung entschieden haben das
habe ich zwei plaketten die wir wieder
raus ja aber das kriegen wir zu
kompliziert wenn ich hier so einen
kleinen vortrag halte dann muss ich
einen einfachen begriff dafür haben und
es ist wird jeder verstehen dass ich
ihnen nicht böse meine tue ich auch
nicht also wir haben uns dann immer
weiter zurückgezogen bis auf den
jetzigen letzten bis auf die letzte
letzte insel dass wir sagen wer geimpft
ist jedenfalls geschützt vom schweren
krankheitsverlauf das stimmt auch nicht
ganz weil es liegen gebucht hatte auf
den intensivstationen die auch schwer
krank sind und es sterben auch
gemusterte also alles sehr fragwürdig
ich will jetzt nichts gegen das impfen
sagen bin dreimal geimpft aber
jedenfalls die sich nicht impfen lassen
dafür verantwortlich machen dass das
dass der die infektionsraten steigen und
dass das land nicht herauskommt aus der
pandemie das ist eine wirklich üble
geschichte der seiten sei dreht ist das
schwarzweiß und da erwarte ich den
bundespreis die impfung bringt weder den
absoluten ausgang aus der pandemie wie
es die impfpflicht befürworter behaupten
aber es ist auch falsch wie es die
impfgegner behaupten dass sie nichts
nütze und nicht sinnvoll sein sie ist
für die allermeisten menschen in
sinnvoller schutz vor einem schweren
verlauf aber sie bringt eben nicht den
völligen die völlige sicherheit und den
völligen ausgang aus
ich habe gemerkt an dem was das an
reaktionen auf meine bitte um verzeihung
das war eine
symbolische geschichte wir haben hier
immer nena und ich habe immer der
verunglimpfung der nicht geimpften
widersprochen
aber
dass die ungeimpften wie dich da
gemeldet haben rechtsradikal wären oder
verschwörungstheoretiker oder sonstige
spinner das kann ich nicht sagen sondern
ich glaube mein eindruck war dass sind
menschen aus der mitte der gesellschaft
und das müssen wir endlich mal begreifen
dass das keine rang figuren sind
irgendwie obskur sondern sie sind mitten
aus der gesellschaft das sind ärzte
dabei rechtsanwälte krankenschwestern
das wissen wir doch alles krankenpfleger
die jeweils ihre individuelle begründung
haben warum zu sich impfen lassen
möchten das ist auch ihr gutes recht
weil das ist nicht vorgeschrieben und
dann müssen wir sie auch verteidigen und
dürfen sie nicht so niedermachen lassen
wie das passiert ist solider als
schutzpatron der menschen die sich
heute aber es war damals in vernichtende
absicht geschrieben weil damals las ich
da so werden wir die ungeimpften
unter seinen schutzmantel nimmt das
ganze
wurde zeichen unserer finde ich nicht
nicht mehr gut debattenkultur das nicht
mehr über die qualität der argumente
beurteilt wird was jemand sagt sondern
darüber wer dafür beifall klatschen ein
riesenproblem auch für politiker man
kann das richtige sagen und man von den
falschen leuten bei fall kriegt wird es
darüber diffamiert und das ist falsch
wir müssen doch in der sache
argumentieren und die qualität der
argumente auseinandernehmen und nicht
danach irgendwie sich richten wir
applaudiert oder nicht sonst gibt man
übrigens auch den falschen leuten die
ganz große deutungshoheit denjenigen die
noch bestimmen was man sagen darf oder
was nicht wir müssen über die qualität
der argumente streiten genau da wo ich
noch ein sachliches argument einbringen
und zwar der hauptgrund warum überhaupt
über eine impfpflicht gesprochen wurde
oder weil man ermutigt wurde sich zu
impfen das war noch bevor überhaupt
nicht immer schafft dabei hat man
gedacht hoffentlich kommt einer
hoffentlich kommt eines klar vor zwei
jahren her da hat man sich geimpft die
sie gerade gesagt haben und dann dachte
man nach der zweiten impfung alles gut
so wurde es ja vom vorherigen
gesundheitsminister auch propagiert dann
hieß es okay das reicht es doch nicht
mal brauchen die dritte impfung aber das
hauptargument bus immer gegen warum muss
man sich impfen oder warum gibt es doch
dann weil die intensivstation komplett
überlastet sind das teile ich nach wie
vor wenn die intensivstation überlastet
sind dann bricht das gesundheitssystem
zusammen habe ich erwarte ja vom staat
insbesondere von den deutschen staat ja
dass er dafür in der lage ist das
gesundheitssystem
so in wie sagt man auf in schach oder so
modern zu führen dass genau hier kein
engpass entsteht ja und das ist die
hauptaufgabe von gesundheitsminister
nicht als er uns ein schlecht ja nicht
dass er uns hier einschränkt damit
sondern er ist dafür verantwortlich
nicht nochmal locker und nochmal
einschränkungen und jetzt schon wieder
erzählen in drei oder was im september
oktober kommt dann die vierte welle
jürgen hat das schon wieder
den punkt sechste impfungen das schöne
ist ja dass wir bleiben beim thema
freiheit und gehen weiter zu dem
statement von frauke werk heute abend ja
wir müssen unseren freiheits muskel
wieder trainieren denn die der
ausnahmezustand der letzten zwei jahre
mit tiefgreifenden grundrechtseingriffen
der darf nicht zur normalität werden ich
finde so laufen aber gerade die debatten
im land zum teil denn wenn wir jetzt zum
glück dafür haben wir freien demokraten
gekämpft nicht mehr eine allgemeine
masken pflicht haben dann ist das doch
kein masken verbot für alle die sich
schützen wollen und zum beispiel im
supermarkt zum eigenschutz weiter in der
ft2 maske tragen ich finde wir müssen
einfach darüber diskutieren die pandemie
ist nicht vorbei aber ihr charakter hat
sich verändert die infektionszahlen bei
omikron sie sind zwar hoch sie haben
sich aber entkoppelt von der frage der
krankenhauseinweisung und erst recht
intensiv pflichtigen patientenzahlen und
da muss doch in einem freiheitlichen
staates gelten eigenverantwortung first
verbote second es ist nicht aufgabe des
staates die allgemeinen lebensrisiken zu
minimieren in einem staat der auch ein
verantwortungs fähige bürgerinnen und
bürger von denen ausgeht und da ist im
moment viel zu tun die debatte hat sich
leider sehr verschoben sie haben völlig
recht ich möchte auch nicht in einem
land leben wo die freiheit nichts mehr
gilt dann kann ich auswandern da lebe
ich irgendwo wo ich tomatenpflanze und
jeden tag diese aber nicht mehr
weil ich kann in deutschland
verschiedene es nicht leiden unter
anderem den umgang mit minderheiten wie
ich jetzt gelernt habe das hätte ich nie
für möglich gehalten da müssen wir was
aufarbeiten aber ich möchte in einem
freien land leben und ich habe in den
letzten wochen und monaten beobachtet
wie auch in zeitungen
in artikeln von wissenschaftlern
historiker politologen der begriff der
freiheit zerlegt worden ist als sei der
fragwürdig als komme es darauf nicht
mehr an wer redet eigentlich heute von
freiheiten ziehe als liberale politiker
haben das wahrscheinlich auch beobachtet
ich bin darüber erschrocken wenn wir mal
so weit sind dass wir theoretisch
darüber reden dass wir gar keine
freiheit mehr brauchen sondern das
anderes wichtiger ist und dass es sie
haben das ja immer wieder sich anhören
müssen das ist die beschwörer der
freiheit sind die uns ins unglück führen
dann müssen wir dann wirklich dann
schrillen bei mir sämtliche alarmglocken
und dann müssen wir ja möglicherweise
gehen wir irgendwann mal auf die strasse
ich dann auch frau geht's haben sie denn
das gefühl dass sie noch in einem
freiheitlichen land leben naja sagen wir
mal so ich habe manchmal das gefühl dass
viele sagen wir wollen unseren alten
kaiser wilhelm wiederhaben wieder diese
alt diese führungsperson die jetzt sagt
wo es langgeht und selber entscheidungen
treffen das ist dann schon schwierig und
ich möchte im moment wirklich kein
politiker sein weil egal was du machst
du kannst so viel falsch machen das fing
an mit corona die einband dafür die
entscheidungen die anderen die gegen
auch jetzt der krieg man ist dafür mann
ist dagegen es ist schwierig aber
ich finde einfach der ton muss sich
verbessern ich finde freiheit bedeutet
auch dass man den anderen die freiheit
lässt seine meinung zu äußern
und man soll sich selber auch die
freiheit geben seine meinung zu ändern
weil ganz viele halten an ihren einmal
gefassten thesen fest weil sie nicht
schwach oder oder ich habe ein schwaches
rückgrat oder ich falle um es muss sich
auf die fdp öfter mal hören nein man
muss auch mit man muss auch sehen dass
sich zeiten ändern situationen ändern
und dann muss man flexibel
im kopf sein und umdenken man muss man
auch den mut haben zu sagen damals hat
es gepasst jetzt passt es nicht mehr wir
müssen jetzt einen anderen weg gehen
ohne angst davor zu haben lena duos ich
ich hab mal gesagt
das recht auf irrtum gehört zur freiheit
da ich wünsche mir dass das in den
medien mal selbst kritisch diskutiert
wird was in den medien in den in den
meisten jedenfalls in den letzten
monaten alles geschrieben worden ist
über diese geschichte und was an
irrtümern verkündet worden ist und
unrecht getan worden ist gegenüber
anderen die eine andere meinung
vertreten haben man kann ja heute noch
lesen habe ich jetzt gerade in einer
großen überregionalen zeitung in einem
leitartikel das eigentlich die maske
pflicht für immer weiter gelten sollte
für etwa oder für irgendeine zeitung was
war nun stopps wieder erschrocken habe
ich auch gelesen und war ganz plakativ
vom wie würde das unser land verändern
wenn wir ständig wenn wir in einem
supermarkt kommen auch in drei vier fünf
jahren in den maske aufziehen müssen
lieber himmel dann gehe ich mich hier
auch gerne die frage an freud heute
denke ich habe auch diese angst hat
heute berkay diesen bürgerinnen wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass die masken
pflicht einfach meine kleine schwester
diesen 120 hat heute die letzte klausur
geschrieben hier und ich habe heute
morgen gesagt wie schön endlich mal
wieder eine klasse ohne maske gestern
beide freedom day was am sonntag maske
ist gefallen dann guckt man sagt nee ich
schreibe die ganze klausur mit maske
meine schwester ist geimpft sitzt einem
einzel tisch mit abstand von dem anderen
nicht abzuschreiben und muss erika somit
mass gestoppt weil hört das thema auf
also dafür haben wir gesorgt nach dem
zweiten vierten ist damit schluss leider
konnten doch leider nicht naja es sei
denn sie missbrauchen die hotspot
regelung und meinen sie seien ein
flächendeckender hotspot aber sie können
höchstens bis zum 24 das was sie schon
als landesregelung hatten weitergelten
lassen danach können sie das nicht mehr
als landesregelung machen wir haben das
begrenzt auf krankenhäuser pflegeheime
öffentlichen personennahverkehr man kann
nicht mehr in schulen oder am
arbeitsplatz oder im supermarkt eine
allgemeine masken pflicht verhängen die
hotspots das soll wirklich die
möglichkeit seien regional zu reagieren
aber es gibt ja leider die anzeichen
dass einige meinen sie klären einfach
mal ihr ganzes bundesland zum hotspot
wachsamkeit gefordert aber daran wie
viel wie viel prügel einstecken dafür
überhaupt dafür einzustehen dass man
wenn die situation sich ändert auch die
gesetze ändern muss und dass auch die
regeln angepasst werden müssen dass das
macht mir eben wirklich sorge freiheit
wird diffamiert da wird von wohl der
liberalismus gesprochen ich würde eher
sagen wir haben ganz viel wohl guerilla
los und diesem land ja die freiheit wird
diffamiert ich habe am wochenende
gelesen der süddeutschen zeitung
suppenkasper freiheit aber nicht ein
einziges darum bin ich kein argument
dafür warum diese schwerwiegenden
grundrechtseingriffe die wir uns bis vor
zwei jahren nicht hätten träumen lassen
dieser republik warum die jetzt
gerechtfertigt sein zu verlängern man
wird als ungezogenes kind dargestellt
wenn man das mal in frage gestellt wurde
bislang das wort gibt nach hinten und
zieht die ganze tischdecke mitte wo sind
ein klub rechtsverteidiger die
politik nie gesagt haben dass jedes
kriminalitätsopfern grund seien maximal
überwachung zu fordern diese logik ist
gefährlich zu sagen jeder mögliche
krankheit oder todesfall rechtfertigt
jedes scharfe staatliche massive bürger
unterschrieben jedoch wie empfinden sie
das denn hat für sie auch die korona
pandemie vielleicht auch die
staatsgläubigkeit der deutschen zum
vorschein gebracht dieses form und hafte
diesen menschen der regel macht dem man
will als ich sagen wir so
auf das statement zurückzukommen
ich fühle mich immer noch frei in
deutschland trotz maske das ist für mich
jetzt nicht die alles entscheidende
schlimmste einschränkung an sich für
mich ist immer noch primär wenn die
intensivstationen
noch freie kapazitäten haben kann man
maske tragen muss es nicht mich nervt
die maske tatsächlich aber für mich
jetzt nicht so elementar und nicht so
eine große einschränkung an sich die
maßnahmen vielmehr die kann ich
tatsächlich frage stellen das ist so
glaubt noch wer kommt denn den
bauaufwand bilden sie jetzt erwachsener
mann ich möchte ich frage mich aber
fahren möchten sie jetzt erwachsener
mann dass ihnen jemand vorgibt die
entscheidung sie tragen jetzt die maske
schröder wollen sie nicht selber also
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich fühle mich
völlig ich bin 29 jahre alt ich kann
selber entscheiden wann ich eine maske
tragen soll war nicht wann ich es tue
finden sie dass dieser form und zb hat
ja nie de facto so eine allgemeine
masten pflicht und auch in england gibt
es das nie mehr finden sie es richtig
dass ihnen der staat vorschreibt ziehen
sie die maske auf da komme ich wieder
darauf zurück und vorhergesagt hat
verteidigungsministerin mit erfahrung
oder gesundheitsminister mit erfahrung
ich unterstelle grundsätzlich weil ich
den menschen ich bin gut gläubiger
mensch vom grund her und wenn man mir
sagt es hilft in der sache man kann
entweder nicht anstecken und man wird
vor allem nicht angesteckt dann habe ich
insbesondere am anfang daran geglaubt
dass es hilfreich ist ich habe am anfang
sogar die maske selbst freiwillig
getragen als noch kein impfstoff gab
jetzt aufgrund der maßnahmen sei es am
flughafen darf man nicht miteinander
setzen und auf den toiletten männer
toiletten dann plötzlich fünf toiletten
2 und damit abgedeckt dann steht man
hintereinander geht mit dem flugzeug
rein sitzt nebeneinander komplett mit
maske ich bestelle mir ne cola oder und
bio was auch immer und dann mal einer
maske ab 10 die kann natürlich nicht
nach ja ich will mal was positives
erzählen moment unbedingt
am samstag auf dem wochenmarkt am
prenzlauer berg da sind nur noch
höchstens zehn prozent obwohl der maske
vorgeschrieben mit maske rumgelaufen die
anderen haben sie nicht mehr getragen es
war ein herrliches gefühl freiheit
schluss war
stets mit ihrem thema und da ändern wird
mein kurs weniger befreit obwohl
vielleicht hat es im großen sind ihm
doch etwas damit zu tun ja natürlich hat
es auch was mit freiheit zu tun wir
haben ja alle in der letzten zeit und
sehr verändert und sind sehr locker
geworden und sehr tolerant und das
transgendern gehört ja auch dazu aber es
gibt natürlich auch bereiche wo es
überhand nimmt zum beispiel in amerika
thomas ist eine schwimmerin aber es
eigentlich als mann geboren und hat
schwamm auch als man aber dann meinte
sie doch ihren
doch dazu zu stehen dass sie doch
eigentlich eher eine frau ist und bei
wettkämpfen schwimmt sie jetzt
sämtlichen frauen davon ganz klar als
man hat die breitere schultern völlig
anderen muskulatur ist viel kräftiger
und
das ist finde ich gegenüber den
biologischen frauen schon mega ungerecht
weil gerade es gibt viele sportarten da
ist nun mal ein riesenunterschied und
ich bin der meinung
dass sollte es ein regel umgehen bei ich
finde natürlich auch das transgender die
möglichkeit haben sollen sport zu
treiben aber da muss man wirklich
regelungen finden es gibt auch
sportarten wo es nicht so wichtig ist
oder aber man sagt ihm die beim boxen es
gibt vom welter und fliegen bis zum
schwergewicht unterschiedliche klassen
vielleicht kann man da solche regelungen
einführen aber das was jetzt so langsam
auch in anderen sportbereichen schule
schule macht das sollte man schnellen
riegel vor setzen weil das ist den
frauen gegenüber ungerecht vor allen
dingen den frauen die früher in der ddr
oder auch in china eher männliche
hormone gespritzt bekommen haben die
dann verteufelt wurden die medizinisch
körperlich fertig gemacht wurden durch
das doping und jetzt mit einem mal
passiert so etwas
das stimmt etwas absolut nicht ja ich
finde es atemberaubend mit welcher
selbstverständlichkeit frühere männer in
frauen-wettbewerbe eintreten die wissen
doch wie ungefähr das ist manchmal vor
einer der klitschko-brüder oder ins
frauenboxen gehen und sagen jetzt
erfahrung ja ja und dann kämpfte
schwergewicht gegen eine halben meter
kleine frau die auch hat so breit ist
wie er das ist doch völlig unmöglich das
muss natürlich von den
sportorganisationen
untersagt werden ganz einfach oder das
muss unbedingt untersagt wenn und es
gibt ja auch die möglichkeit zum
beispiel vor vielen jahren die hieß
marien ja
thailändische kickboxerin als ein
kickboxer aber in thailand
transgender
dass man das aber nicht mal wirklich was
brauche ich erkenne das sofort aber neue
männer fallen drauf rein auf jeden fall
hat die ihm
aber sie hat eben geschwind und schick
zurecht gemacht gegen männer gefaltet
und hat gewonnen und das ist richtig so
sollte man es machen man kann ja sich
aus lehm und ich finde auch transgender
sollten die möglichkeit haben sport zu
machen aber doch bitte in ihrer
gewichtsklasse
und und ich finde es nicht schön wenn
fußballer oder auch boxer oder egal
welche sportler aufgrund ihrer sexuellen
neigung diskriminiert werden das ist ein
problem ich glaube was uns noch nicht
gelungen ist bei diesem thema wenn es um
gesellschaftliche toleranz und so geht
ist mal zu differenzieren zwischen
respekt vor der identität wie sich ein
mensch fühlt wie er sein privatleben
führen will oder wie er seine identität
geschlechtlich sieht und andererseits
trotzdem ein paar biologischen fakten
die eine rolle spielen weshalb ist eben
verschiedene die verschiedenen
sportarten für männer und frauen
getrennt gibt oder auch verschiedene
andere dinge für männer und frauen
getrennt angeboten werden dass wir das
trennen von der frage nicht das eine ist
besser oder schlechter oder geschlechter
irgendwie andere aufwerten oder abwerten
oder sagen männer oder frauen können
irgendetwas nicht aber trotzdem die
sachlichkeit zu haben es gibt
biologische tatsachen die eine
auswirkung haben die auch zählen in
bestimmten bereichen nicht im sinne von
hör- oder schlechter wert ich aber dass
man zu trennen und ich glaube das
gelingt noch nicht und wenn sie es sonst
so viel heißt von otis 1
fakten sehen dann glaube ich brauchen
wir darüber noch mal eine debatte wie
geht man damit klug um mit dem respekt
vor unterschiedlichen gefühlen und
identitäten einerseits und den
biologischen fakten andererseits stehen
dann noch ziemlich am anfang also das
glaube ich wirklich noch einiges zu tun
auch mit der selbstverständlichkeit des
umgangs denn gerade wenn man jetzt eben
dann fängt zb wurde ich ja von der
bildzeitung mal aufgefordert ein
interview zu führen weil jetzt das
buchstabieren nicht mehr mit a wie anton
und baby berta und so weil das ja
irgendwie
geschlechterspezifisch ist sondern man
sollte jetzt städtenamen dafür nehmen
ich finde es ist ein völlig falsches
selbstverständliches wie man eben mit
trance kindern umgeht ihn ist das nicht
wichtig sie wollen respektiert werden
und sie wollen
gleichberechtigt sein und sehen wollen
gleiche voraussetzungen nahm aber
natürlich nur so dies auch geht und ich
muss mal eine frage stellen wie
reagieren denn die zuschauer auf so
wettbewerber pfeifen die dann wenn der
wenn der frühere man oben offen aber es
gab auf twitter ich gerade eingestellt
sind daran aber ich habe meine lösung
mit dabei vielleicht könnte man ja
einfach dann wenn es dann mehr werden
transgender olympische spiele macht ist
es wo genau dann für die gruppe aber da
wäre dann auch das problem wieder wenn
ein mann zu einer frau wird ist es ja
auch wieder anders als wenn eine frau zu
einem mann wird auch da hätten wir
wieder die gewichtsunterschiede aber
eher schröder wie sehen sie das denn
setzt sich dieser fall eigentlich ein
komplett das leistungsprinzip außer
kraft
es gibt gewisse punkte wo es klemmt zu
schweigen das ist jetzt sozusagen das
hat meine frau hat der sendung auch
gerade bei meiner davon wir waren ja
letzte woche gemeinsam aufnahmen und top
veranstaltung war eine super
veranstaltung ging wenn männer und
frauen männer und frauen aber natürlich
kann auch eine gewisse dynamik entstehen
deshalb wie viele männer zusammen sind
im fußball sondern so eine
gruppendynamik andersherum bei frauen
kann das genauso passieren und manchmal
das dann auch einfach besser
gesagt werden darf man keine ahnung hat
wie in der politik soll es ja auch sein
sollten auch in der lage sein zu sagen
ich habe keine ahnung oder
mich zu diesem thema am besten wer
könnte denn die lösung aussehen es ist
ja jetzt das beispiel mit dem schwimmen
ist ein beispiel was wird sich ja in
vielen disziplinen noch stellen was
könnte denn eine möglichkeit seien
einfach die leute in den klassen zu
lassen ist guter vorschlag was du
gemacht hast also wenn es wirklich genug
menschen reagiert auf die das zutrifft
dann könnte man natürlich eigenständige
wettbewerbe austragen aber ich glaube
dass es noch schwierig im moment stehen
insbesondere die weiblichen
sportlerinnen davon einer schwierigen
entscheidungen nämlich ob sie
boykottieren oder sich in einem unfairen
wettbewerb gegeben die müssen sie
dramatisch und das kann so finde ich
nicht sein wie das im moment läuft
biologische männer dann vorteile haben
und am ende der leistungsgedanke des
sports nicht mehr funktioniert dass sie
vom gleichen körperlichen
voraussetzungen ausgehen die dann
miteinander frauen sollten nicht eine
situation gebracht werden dass sie
boykottieren müssen das ist aufgabe das
ist irgendwie das zu klären aber es gibt
ja auch sportarten die die man ruhig
machen kann zum beispiel der reitsport
oder schießen also es gibt einige
sportarten ja doch die nicht von der
muskelkraft sondern eher von
geschicklichkeit oder konzentration
abhängig sind
ja und insofern sollte man sich
vielleicht erst mal als transgender auf
diese sportarten das übergeben in den
sportverbänden weil wir sind am ende
unserer sendung gekommen und ich möchte
die heute gerne mit den worten von frau
teuteberg beenden eigenverantwortung
first verbote second das war für mich
der satz heute arbeiten nach acht
schönen abend ihnen nach und hoffentlich
bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]